hi in this module i'm going to be
talking about the notion of our
consistency this is going to lead us to
a look at algorithm called ac3 which is
going to enable us to prune domains much
more aggressively than before in the
context of backtracking search
let's begin
first i want to review backtracking
search
so backtracking search is recursive
procedure
where
takes
a partial assignment x
its weight
and the domains of each of the variables
in the csp
if all the variables have already been
assigned in x
then we just
see if it's better than the best
assignment we've seen so far and if so
updated and then we return this is the
base case
otherwise we're going to choose an
unassigned variable x i
we're going to look at all the values in
the domain of x i and order them
according to some heuristic lcv
and now we're going to step through each
of the values v
in that order
we're going to compute
the weight update
based on the xi's
being set to v
and if this is zero then we can just
stop recursing right there
um otherwise we're going to
use this updated uh
assignment
to
um as an input into the look at head
algorithm to reduce the domains
and now if any of the domains become
empty then again we stop recursing
otherwise we recurse
so last time we talked about
the heuristics for choosing unassigned
variable
ordering the values these are the mcb
and lcv heuristics and then we looked at
forward checking which was a one step
look at now we're going to
upgrade that to ac3
so before we get into ac3 i need to talk
about our consistency using us let's use
a simple example
so suppose we have just two
variables x i and xj xi can be one two
three four or five and x j can be one or
two
so
and x i and x j are related be via a
single factor which says that their sum
must equal 4 exactly
so what does it mean to enforce our
consistency on let's say x i
this means i'm going to go through each
of the values in the domain of x i and
try to eliminate it if eliminated if it
can't be satisfied by any value in xj's
domain okay so let's try this so look at
one
does there exist any possible setting of
x j so that i can do one plus something
to get four
one plus one is not four one plus two is
not four so therefore one is just
impossible
without even knowing the value of xj so
let me eliminate it
what about 2
well i can set xj to 2
to get 4 so that's okay
notice that it's fine that 1
plus two isn't four it just matters that
there exists
one of the values in xj that work so
let's leave two alone so what about
three
well three plus one is four so that's
okay too
what about four
i can't add four to one or two to get
four so
that gets eliminated and same with five
so in the end
enforcing our consistency on x i results
in a smaller domain which only consists
of two and three
so notice i can eliminate values without
even knowing what
the exact value of xj is
so more formally our consistency
is a property which i'll explain
so a variable x i
is are consistent with respect to
another variable xj if for each
value
in the domain of x x i
there exists some other value
in the domain of x j such that
essentially all the factors check out so
formally what that means is that if you
look at all the factors
whose scope contains x i and x j and you
evaluate that factor
on x i
x j
then you get something that's not zero
okay so an enforcing our consistency
is a procedure that takes two variables
and just simply removes the values from
domain i
to make x i are consistent with respect
to xj
exactly what we did on the example on
the previous slide
so let's
revisit the australia example
and apply
ac3
okay
so
here is the empty assignment
and here are all the domains of each of
the variables
so let's suppose we set wa
to be red okay so as before we eliminate
um the other
uh
values from was domain of course
and then we enforce our consistency on
the neighbors of wa in this case ntnsa
so out goes red on both of these
um and now we
continue try to enforce our consistency
on the neighbors of ntnsa
but in this case i can't actually
eliminate anything
so
now
we're going to recurse
and suppose now in the next level of
backtracking we assign nt green
so now again
we're going to
apply
enforce our consistency on the neighbors
of nt
so that will eliminate green
from these two
so notice that one step
should look very very familiar this is
exactly forward checking
but ac3 doesn't stop there and then it
says enforce our consistency on the
neighbors of q and sa okay so let's uh
enforce our consistency on the neighbors
of sa
that eliminates
blue from
its neighbors
and now let's enforce our consistency on
the neighbors of q
so that eliminates red
from the neighbors
and now let's enforce our consistency on
the neighbors
of nsw
well that eliminates green
and at this point
now we're done
so notice what happened
each of these domains is only left with
one value
so even though we're still in the
context of backtracking search at nt and
we're still trying to figure out what to
do with nt by looking ahead we've
actually
seen what
values are even possible
and
we essentially solve the problem so now
formally we haven't set these values yet
we just eliminated their domains
but backtracking search
uh recurs
recursing on the rest of these values
should be really a walk in the park you
go into essay and you said set it to
blue set uh q to red
um and a sub u to green and v to red and
you're done
so this shows you the power of the ac3
with one fell swoop it basically can
clean out a lot of the domains and
reveal kind of what the actual
assignments
values are possible here
so here is ac3
more formally so remember forward
checking
is what you do is when you assign
the variable xj to some value xj
literally xj
you set the domain
to only include that value and then you
enforce our consistency on the neighbors
of
neighbors x i with respect to x j
okay so here's a picture so you're
setting x j
and then you consider all the neighbors
of x j
for example x i and then you enforce our
consistency on x i so you try to
propagate what you know about xj to xi
and try to eliminate excise domains
so now ac3 just repeatedly enforces our
consistency and there's nothing left to
do
so here's the algorithm
we're going to maintain a working set
of variables that we need to go process
so we start with xj which is
the variable that we just assigned
and while there's still
variables to process we're going to just
remove any xj from
s this order doesn't really matter here
and then for each of the neighbors x i
of x
x j
we're going to enforce our consistency
on that neighbor with respect to x j so
propagate the constraints out
and now if the domain
of x i changed then we're going to add x
i to s because we know more about x i
now and we can hopefully propagate the
information farther to its neighbors
so notice that
a variable could be revisited multiple
times so this is kind of like breadth
first search with exception that
you might visit a node
more than once because you might
propagate some value to another neighbor
and that
uh value might be
constrained something else and then you
might get more additional information
back um and this can kind of go on for a
while but it does run in
polynomial time you can read the notes
for a little bit more details about the
running time
so
as great as ac3 might seem it's not a
panacea and it shouldn't be and it
shouldn't be surprising because solving
a csp should take an exponential time
in general and ac3 isn't doing
any sort of backtracking search
so here is a small example that shows
when ac3 doesn't do anything
so here we have a mini australia here
with three
variables
and suppose each of them can either be
red or blue red or blue red or blue
so immediately you should
realize that there is no
consistent assignment to three variables
with only two
colors such that any pair can't have the
same color
but what happens
if you run ac3
okay so let's look at this uh factor
here so w-a-n-t
so this is r consistent
because if i assign w-a red then nt can
be blue if i assign wa blue then nt can
be red so if i just look at this local
configuration there's no problem and
analogously if i look over here there's
no problem and if i look over here
there's no problem
so ac3 doesn't detect a problem
even though there's no satisfying
assignment
so the intuition here is that ac3 and in
general our consistency all it's doing
is look looking locally at the graph
and it says it only
detects problems that are kind of
blatantly wrong which can be detected
locally
but you can't avoid
exhaustive search to actually detect the
kind of the deep problems
so let me summarize here enforcing our
consistency
is a way to take what you know about one
variable's domain to propagate that
information via the factors to make
reduce the domains of its neighbors
forward checking only applies our
consistency to its neighbors
and this was already somewhat effective
ac3 just takes that
to the extreme limit and enforces our
consistency on the neighbors and their
neighbors and their neighbors and so on
until you converge
so it's trying to kind of exhaustively
enforce our consistency as much as
possible to eliminate as much
of the values from the domains as
possible
and
of course remember that
ac3 forward checking or look at head
algorithms which are used in the context
of backtracking search to detect
inconsistencies so we can prune early
and also to maintain these domains so
that we can use them for heuristics such
as mcb and lcd and look ahead turns out
to be very very important for
backtracking search if you can look
ahead and detect
inconsistency then that saves you the
work of actually having to recurse and
explore a combinatorial number of
possibilities
okay that's the end